- We're back with Khloe Kardashian.
(audience applause)
Give it up.
Alright, so you shared this season
that you're training yourself
to unlove your ex, Tristan.
So just how'd you do that?
Asking for a friend?
(laughter)
Just, I don't know
just if you have any paper or pen.
I know like, I'm like no it's hard.
I think it's the most
ridiculous thing sometimes.
Like when something doesn't work out
and you're in a relationship
and you're so deeply
in love and people are like,
Oh yeah, well why can't you?
And I'm like, I think I might
always still love that person.
I dunno if that goes away.
- No, and I don't think it goes away.
Like my ex-husband, I
genuinely still love.
And I want the best for him
and I'm rooting for him.
- Absolutely.
- We all I think just change or evolve
or you know that sometimes that's not
it's just not a right fit for you.
- And what, when I said I'm learning how
to unlove Tristan I think people,
whether it be family or friends
or anyone that you're
telling your story to.
They're like OK so move on.
And I'm like, I know.
- Oh well let me find the switch.
- [Khloe] Right?
Like it's not that easy.
- Yeah.
- Just even the habits that you built,
the repetition, the routine.
Like when something good happened,
I would call Tristan or something bad or
that's what I did.
Any little thing
I would share my life with him.
And so learning to just reprogram myself
like, even though,
if someone did something bad to me
it doesn't just mean I'm like
there's a wall and I've built it up.
I know that this isn't
the right thing for me
and I need to slowly heal and move on.
But it doesn't happen overnight.
- No, I, I love that
and I love that you're open about it
because I am as well.
And I think in therapy
too, I, I remember um,
I feel like she said
something like, you know
it took you how long to fall in love?
You know what I'm saying?
All those tips.
So it's gonna take you
at least that amount, you know?
- Right.
- To, to fall out.
But I don't think it's
the same for everyone too.
And I think it's really hard when you're
in the public eye and
people judge the situation.
'Cause it's like
- Correct.
- You don't know the whole situation.
- You don't know.
- You only see what we're
allowing you to see.
Right?
- Right.
And no one knows the entire,
even I think sometimes our close family
and friends don't know
the whole situation.
- Yeah.
'Cause we can be, I can be very,
like, I'm very outgoing
and don't have a filter,
but like I can filter.
- Yeah.
- And I think for me, like I've always
been really proud of myself
the way that I'm still
able to love people even
if they've wronged me and I'm still able.
- Me too.
- Yeah.
And, but how other people are like,
- Oh you need like you
need to be more vindictive
or get them back or eye for an eye.
I'm so not that person.
- Me neither.
- Like I'm like why?
I think it's a waste of energy.
I really don't care that much
to respond in that way.
- That's literally what I say.
I don't care that much.
I seems like a lot.
- It seems like a lot.
It's not my personality.
So, why am I forcing myself to act a way?
I would never act
- Yeah.
- on my own.
But, also I think it
shows our kids so much.
I think like we're allowed sometimes when
people hurt you, it's not even personal.
And like,
- Sometimes they're hurting
an they don't know how to.
It's more about that person.
- And we're all here to make mistakes.
We're all on a journey of not perfection,
of journey, of just
figuring out our stuff.
And sometimes people make
mistakes at our expense
but I don't think that's
a reflection of me.
I think that's
- Definitely not.
- That's how their journey is.
And if I'm able to be
strong enough to endure it
and say you know what?
You're forgiven but I'm
still gonna walk away
but just show my kids that I can
still love someone that's made mistakes.
I think that's a powerful thing.
- OK, me too.
- Yeah. And for our kids to see that.
And that's everlasting
love and that's a love
that transcends to all areas of life.
And that's what kids need to know is
you can still love
people even if you're not
I'm not getting something.
- In love, that kind of thing.
- Yeah.
I'm not getting something in return.
I just wanna give you my love.
You shouldn't give to get.
Just give to give.
- Yeah.
It's a gift.
Agreed.
All right, well you said your brand,
Good American, was born
out of your own insecurities.
Can you tell us more about that?
- Yeah, so I, we started
Good American about
it's our sixth year anniversary.
(crowd applauds)
Thank you.
- I, can I be honest
with you, I did not know
that that was your brand and I own
Good American jeans.
- No way.
- I'm not kidding.
And I was like, when I
was reading this script
last time I was like, no way.
I was like I didn't know that you could,
I didn't know that you
were involved at all.
I didn't know that that was your brand.
- Yeah.
- I had no idea.
And I just like them,
'cause they fit an ass?
- They do.
All different size asses.
- Yeah.
- But they fit an ass,
but like it doesn't show, you know,
like the small of your back?
Like it's always smaller her so
- There's a no gap waist band.
- Exactly.
- Yes.
- Well done.
- Thank you.
- Just wanted to say that.
I was like, it's nice.
It's nice.
So why, you started it six years ago?
- Yeah.
Well we started it before then,
but we launched six years ago
when it became public.
But you know, I, my weight
has always fluctuated.
When I was younger, I was much bigger.
- Yeah.
- In size.
But I always thought I
was fabulous and sexy.
And I was probably way more confident the
chubbier I was, which is so funny.
- What is that? I know.
- I don't know what that is.
- Me too.
- But that's okay.
That's a whole other show.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- And when I used to shop at stores
with my sisters we would go to boutiques
or some department stores,
and they didn't carry my size.
Or if they did, I was
in a different section.
I would go upstairs
and my sisters were on a different floor
and I would always get really embarrassed.
- That sucks. Yeah.
- It sucks.
And I never wanted to shop
with my friends or my siblings.
But then also nothing was cool.
Like we were told
Oh you have four styles
if you were a bigger girl
these are your four styles that choose
or a mumu.
Like I'm like this is
so wild that the fashion
industry is gonna tell
me what I want to wear.
And I was always super confident.
So I wanted to be in the body con dress.
I wanted to show my curves
even if I probably didn't look like some
of the other girls wearing those dresses.
But, I liked it.
And so we started Good American.
We started with denim first.
Based off of that, I
just wanted all women.
We go from a double zero to a 32 plus.
All women to feel sexy and
we have all styles.
So, I'm not dictating
what I think women should wear.
If you're a size double zero,
if you wanna wear bell bottoms,
or skinny jean or whatever, wear that.
If you're a size 32
and wanna wear the same thing.
Do it.
Like it's your body, your fashion sense.
- I love that.
I think that's awesome.
- Yeah.
- And then we've ventured out to
we have so many other
divisions and categories.
We have shoes and swimwear and clothing
and boss wear.
Like, more clothes to wear
if you're going to work or whatnot.
And we sell, in order for us to
allow a store to pick up our line,
they're not allowed to
buy their own sizes.
They have to buy the full size range
and they can't separate the size range.
So I don't want any girl to feel
how I felt shopping.
- Yeah.
- And if they're not willing to do that,
with which I get for budget purposes,
I used to own stores so I get it.
But if they're not willing to do that,
we just won't sell the line.
'Cause I don't want any girl to feel
like they're not included.
- I love that you have like a bar
of where how you wanna
sell it and market it.
That's awesome.
So what can you tell us
about the open casting that
you're doing with Good American?
What is this?
- Basically our open casting,
we've done it every year except
for the year of Covid
was the only year we couldn't do it.
And we basically ask that people come,
come as you are.
We have no cookie cutter
woman that we're working
that we're looking for.
And it's basically us
looking for people that model
for Good American.
We call 'em the Good Squad.
Last year we picked seven women,
but there's no number amount.
We can pick 20.
We can pick five.
Just whoever we think really embodies.
- Embodies it.
- Embodies Good American.
And it's all different ethnicities,
all different sizes, heights.
If you have a shaved head,
if you have tattoos
like expose who you are and we love that.
And now we're doing it virtually too.
So you could apply by Zoom.
- Yeah.
If they can't make it to that warehouse.
I love that.
That's so cool.
Well, speaking of good American
Khloe brought a gift for everyone
in our audience.
Good American is the first
fully inclusive fashion
brand to offer trend
for designs made to
fit women of all sizes.
They started with high quality denim
and have extended to
swim, ready to wear shoes
and more.
Always in an inclusive size range
- Thank you ma'am.
And today everyone in the
audience is going home
with a two hundred dollar gift card.
(crowd cheers)
So go online for more
information on Khloe's
open casting call for Good American
and be sure to watch
the Kardashians on HULU.
New Episodes drop Thursday.